[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rex chapman former nba player
former kentucky hoop star twitter legend
by the way and he's got a podcast that's
great it's called charges
it takes audiences on a journey through
some of the most fascinating scandals
that rock the sports world from
brawls to betting to bribery and
everything in between
and rex joins us on the program good
morning rex how's morale
good morning daniel patrick how are you
buddy i'm doing okay
uh are you going to the suns game
tonight
trick question yes okay yes i'm in
phoenix i'm going to the sun's game
i'm trying to go through i'm glad to see
you've got on uh jay bilas and jim
jackson
because i was trying to go through the
the process what thought process was
going on in your mind
uh you know when you saw that this
scotus decision
and you needed something like that you
know guys like jay billis you don't go
call up rex chat well
we can we can talk about you know what
what it was like when you came out of
high school
and what you could have made like if you
were kentucky now
as a sophomore let's say and they they
gave you your name image and likeness
what kind of money do you think you
would make above board at kentucky
i don't i don't know i remember back you
know and
during those times that you know they
sold jerseys
they sold t-shirts the one they got me
was
and students had them everybody seemed
like everybody had them said
i love rex on them it was just real
generic
heart and uh i mean they sold thousands
and thousands of them during my time at
kentucky which
of course i never saw any of so yeah
there you go but you know if you look at
the the landscape now
is this going to change college
athletics if you have
certain states that allow this uh you
know basketball stars
like what would zion williamson be worth
name image and likeness
to spend one year at duke i have no idea
what that is i mean it's it's
like millions of dollars millions of
dollars it's millions of dollars i mean
think about it if uh if you tell college
kids
no class today they go okay they say no
practice today or no
we're not going to pay you or i'm sorry
professional athletes if you
tell professional athletes okay look
guys we're not going to pay this month
or this week they say we're not going to
play yeah
you know and that's what we've been kind
of stuck with for years and years
but this it used to be how how did
athletes get paid back when you were
coming out of high school
either under the table or uh through
some yeah i mean
it it it fostered a you know look
everybody is out there trying to fight
over the the best players in the country
at the highest level 25 schools
football basketball going after the same
kids every year
and you just brought it up if some
states are going to allow this and some
states are not going to
the states that are not going to are
really going to suffer talent wise
the best players just aren't going to
ultimately go to that school
they're going to find another state
where these col and look most
you play college ball dan i mean
most college kids are not going to go
play professional sports
um so look they've got a short window
four or five year window in college to
make a little money off their name
image and likeness is that too much to
ask
without naming names the biggest offer
you got
oh man i would say uh
just a flat five hundred thousand
dollars
in uh uh what do you call it as in
escrow
that i get when i get out um
which you know think about that that's
that's insane insane what
well you didn't have money growing up
and oh and you could take care of your
family right away
with something like that well of course
but and you know the argument i hear
from
from people who've been anti-paying
players in college forever is why don't
one
i don't want an athlete driving around
in an escalade on campus
you know i don't really is that what you
have a problem with you
you don't seem to have a problem with
buffy and mark over in the fraternity
and sorority that are driving their
dad's escalade or their
their mercedes these are these are at
least the guy
they earned this money with something
they did but how
how are you presented an offer like that
it wasn't through me it wasn't to me it
was for sure through my fam
through my parents or my coaches oh wow
okay yeah i was i you know kids are too
young i think i hope
kids are too young to have than to have
adults coming to them offering them you
know because you would have said
yes right i don't know what i would have
said i
i i know what i would have said i would
have immediately
told my dad told my mom and see what
they were going to say
so yeah i mean but you know 16 17 year
old kid you have no idea what's going on
in life
you know much less you know big time
college athletics
help me understand ben simmons if you're
this if you're on the 76ers coaching
student you're doc rivers
so what does the off-season constitute
in relationship to ben
simmons you know i see a lot of a lot of
hate going on out there
with ben and look i get it he's playing
professional sports
um but again he's a he's
very young we didn't we didn't jump on
rajon rondo when he couldn't shoot
after you know his his shooting was an
issue he got better jason kidd he got
better
we weren't expecting them to be great
shoot i remember jason kidd and i
i compare ben a lot with jason you know
ben's bigger but they played
very much the same we used to get mad at
jason
during games because he wouldn't shoot
the ball he didn't have confidence
enough to shoot the ball we had a
veteran team
and if i if i came off a screen or kj
came off a screen and jason wasn't gonna
shoot it
we had two guys and i had two guys in my
lap so we had to beg
jason to shoot it there's it has to be
something that goes on with ben
and i know it's a confidence that
obviously it's a confidence thing he has
no confidence shooting
a jump shot and i can't imagine what
that feels like because he
is extraordinary in
every other facet of the game every
other facet and i'm not ready to say
you can't win with ben simmons as a
point guard in this league because he's
a phenomenal basketball player
but he has to put the work in it has to
come every single day
but what is that though this isn't just
going
out there and shooting a hundred free
throws
i gotta put you in a game situation
where these free throws actually
matter like it's really important like
if you miss this the entire team runs
10 win sprints or whatever it is there
has to be
stakes attached to it shaq could make 20
in a row
in practice yeah uh you know i
i would say look at it look at a young
man right now like michael bridges
in phoenix if you remember a year ago he
had one of the worst jump shots you've
ever seen he got a real hitch in it
where he
almost couldn't release it it was like a
three-part jump shot
and he went to work during the
uh pandemic and i mean to tell you
he's a different guy now it's it's
muscle memory
it's a commitment though it's a
commitment to going in
and not shooting 100 shots it's shooting
500 shots a day
and being committed to being a better
shooter the second he starts feeling a
little bit of confidence
his whole world will change and i i
still believe he's going to be able to
shoot the basketball
i i hope so anyway i wonder if he can
stay in philadelphia though rex
i don't know that that that may that
ship may have sailed
tough city um and look
it's it's not for everybody i'm not sure
that ben and
and and joel are a great match yeah so
maybe it is time
well and mclovin just brought this up
that when
uh ben was the the star when joel embiid
was out
he put up like 42 points against utah he
made 11 or 13 free throws there
it's there i just don't know if
that mental block is going to stay there
and that might be
you got it like markelle fultz couldn't
stay in philadelphia he needed to get
out
and i i don't know if you get ben on a
team that doesn't have great
expectations
and and then he can be you he can grow
his confidence whereas philadelphia
the bar's so high they brought in doc to
win a championship
and you know you got an mvp candidate in
beads uh you got tobias harris you're
spending all that money on like there
the stakes maybe are too high for him
and i think he needs to almost do a
reset
that's okay he can do that i mean
there's going to be no shortage of teams
that want ben simmons
young he's one of the top you know young
players in the nba he's a physical
uh freak of nature fast vision all of
that when i watch him play
i do right now i see a little bit of i'm
gonna go back to jason but just
it's his insecurity shooting the
basketball and when he's on the floor
with you said it tobias harris
and seth curry and guys who are snipers
like that
you can almost see him catch the ball
and be anxious to get the ball to them
because he knows that's you know that's
what they do best
so i think he's going through just
growing pains as a young player
and in one of the toughest sport cities
in the country he's rex chapman former
nba player kentucky hoop star
and uh twitter legend his uh podcast is
charges
who's been on charges as of late uh and
and you're looking at guys who've had
troubled past we've certainly talked
about what yours has been so it's
full disclosure on your part but who uh
who are some of the guests you've had
recently
oh man uh you know re well recently
um chris herron had chris on which was
just a fantastic
pod um i did one that's
actually coming out today that i'm
really excited about as a guy that i
don't know much about hockey i thought
hockey was a new sport
in the south when espn came on in
well you're growing up in kentucky
exactly i thought what is this
cross what is this so um
i forget where where was it oh you got a
hockey player that uh oh oh we got i got
i got uh chris knuckles nylon just uh a
fascinating story and then coming out
next week i believe we've got a
two-parter
with stevie jackson and matt barnes
coming up
so we'll release half the smoke one week
and the rest of the smoke
uh week two but that that really is
fascinating i'm having so much fun with
it it's just
it's awesome getting to know these guys
and letting them tell their stories in
their own words
you know chris herron's story you know
he was a high school legend
in mass in boston uh you know played for
jerry tarkini
uh tarkanian and then you know when
we've
had him on he's scoring drugs in
warm-ups
when he was playing for the celtics he
was getting he was scoring oxy
while wearing his uniform his warm-ups
yeah
yeah you know and the funny thing funny
but uh the thing with chris
herron and spoke with knuckles nylon
all three of us to a person
document 1999
and 2000 as the jumping off point
for just going down the toilet with our
lives
which was when we were all three
introduced to oxycontin
and it was a monster that we just you
know we were we're one of those
we're three of those people that uh
really get along well
with painkillers makes us feel
extraordinarily good
and uh it just uh it started years for
all three of us
of addiction and uh real problems so
i'm just thrilled that these guys are
able to come on and tell their stories
and they then
that they've lived through to see the
other side but the fact that he's out
there i mean you
really need to score oh you do and and
dan i can't
i can't even tell you what that's like
it it there comes a point
where you're so dependent on that
physiologically i mean you you start
feeling it you start feeling sick
and the only thing you can think about
is getting that pill
and putting it in your mouth and getting
it into your systems and i would just
chew them up just to get them into my
bloodstream they taste like crap you
know
but just to get them in my bloodstream
quicker and nothing is more important
think about that
he was out minutes to go before
starting lineups and he's standing on
the corner up there at the garden
waiting for his oxy dealer it's it's
madness it's insane thinking
but that's where we where we were at the
time i got jim jackson on next hour
he's the best jimmy jackson just to say
but if i
forget was an unbelievable basketball
player he gave me fits
uh might be a better analyst he's an
unbelievable basketball analyst he he
puts you on lockdown occasionally
oh did he i think he gave me 51.
i was coming back from a from a thumb
injury
and and uh they went at me
he was in dallas and uh i i think you
have to ask him about it but i think he
gave me 50
michael never gave me 50. he jimmy
jackson gave me 50.
yeah do you think guys circled that uh
that game on their calendar when they
knew that
they were they were gonna face you
uh i hope so because i circled them
well yeah but who did who did you know
you were gonna have
a great game you just couldn't wait you
you never
you you never uh yeah you can uh
okay vinnie del negro you you know
you knew you were gonna light up vinnie
del negro no
man i can't i can't say that video was
great just did
no i didn't okay i did yeah you could
light up vinnie delton a girl
he's my guy yeah yeah well not anymore
hey it's great to talk to you as always
um so no kawhi no chris paul tonight but
you get to watch devin booker
oh man how much fun are these sons and
i'm a homer of course
i'm biased um but look at what's
look at what's left the sons are the
most complete
team left i i feel like they defend
they defend like they defend better than
any of the teams left
they share the ball like a college team
i can't say enough about monty williams
and i've been around this this squad
some
dan you know what a college atmosphere
feels like and when it's really good
it's really good
these players love monty williams
like they love their their favorite
college coach
to a person he's come in and he's
changed the culture
james jones and robert sarver made a
great hire and
the culture has completely changed devin
booker's obviously a star deandre
ayton's
come leaps and bounds so look out for
the suns if they get chris back
and are healthy i don't know anybody can
beat them
i i would ask you this but i know the
answer because you're not gonna
know the answer where can people find uh
your podcast
charges um i'm gonna say anywhere you
can find your podcast
apple spotify youtube all of that stuff
uh i heart radio charges look at you
okay you know look i'm getting the hang
of it you are
you are buddy yeah look at you mature in
there
and it looks like you made your bed too
well i did i got in trouble for not
doing that last time look
dan when you go hardship out of college
it you got it takes some time you know i
love it back then
rex went hardship was it really
were you hardship back home i wasn't
like
how much did your dad make at the time
oh man
he didn't make very much right he wasn't
making very much yeah
but back then you could go hardship
that's what it was called going hardship
um and i remember well almost nobody did
it at the time that i was doing
it it kind of slowed down and i didn't
intend on leaving anyway we were going
on probation you know that
because not because of you right
that's a long time ago i had mashburn on
jamal mashburn on
my other pod i do with josh hopkins uh
the rex chapman show
and i had mashburn on a few weeks ago or
a month or so ago and
he was going through he said you know
that year you know
the first year i came in we had a great
year but we couldn't make the tournament
we were on probation i said sorry
i didn't that team go 13 and 13 that
year
that year they're on probation uh with
patino
they might they may have they may have i
don't know i i
i lose track at real i did a story on
kentucky basketball that year
uh but was that the chris mills fedex
you know well my if i would have stayed
in school
and gone on to be a junior our team
would have been uh myself chris mills
eric manuel laurent ellis and sean kemp
oh it's a squad that's a squad
that's that's that's an ncaa
investigation is what it is
it never materialized
sean kemp wasn't it that eddie sutton's
son
took his s.a.t test for him yeah
allegedly your your your confusing
stories
okay yeah yeah but yeah that was all
kind of going on
[Laughter]
you know it's easy to get confused when
it comes to kentucky basketball there
right
because we're so damn great yes
absolutely that's what i mean
many titles that's what you're talking
about you should be wearing your uniform
tonight
your your phoenix well you got a lot of
uniforms
yeah maybe i'll just wear my uniform
that would be great
like just go with your socks and your
shoes just walk in
yeah shot socks and shooting taped get
together yeah
yeah and nobody's gonna think wow that's
really rex chapman they'll be like that
dude is dressing up like rex chapman
i did that one year for halloween here
you dressed up as you
yeah wait where were you sober at the
time
[Laughter]
it's a jump ball i don't know who knows
uh
have fun tonight behave okay thank you
sons
all right that's uh rex chapman and his
podcast is charges
it's uh it's great revealing he sent me
a couple of episodes
uh that i got to kind of screen for him
but uh
he's doing great take a break back after
this